Let's use DesignaKnit to
create a triangular shawl.
We'll make the shawl exactly the
size we want and we'll make sure
that we can knit it on our machine
with a number of needles available.
We'll also use the yarn
calculation feature to make
sure that we have enough yarn.
In Original Pattern Drafting
start a new file.
I'm planning to use my LK-150 and I've
already swatched and I know my gauge.
So I'll enter it now.
It can always be changed later.
Click piece, >block new piece.
Enter a name.
Now let's size this new
piece to our dimensions.
Use the >fit to width tool.
Since my rulers are showing stitches in
rows, it's prompting me with stitches.
I have 150 needles
available on my machine.
I want my shawl to be 30 inches long,
so I'll switch the rulers to inches
and use the >fit to length tool.
Use the >measure edge
tool to confirm the size.
Remember, we measure counter-clockwise.
And here's a tip.
Click again to turn off
the measuring on one side.
Let's now make this a triangle.
Use the >delete tool, the minus sign.
And since I have >mirroring on,
I just have to remove one point.
That's it.
I have a triangle that I can knit with all
150 needles, but do I have enough yarn?
Let's use DesignaKnit
to calculate it for us.
Click >file >print.
Choose >yarn calculation.
Now, select the >single wrench tool
and tell DesignaKnit about your swatch.
How many stitches and rows
did you knit in your swatch?
How much yarn did you use?
Weighing in grams with a food
scale is best click okay.
And then >preview.
DesignaKnit is telling me how much
yarn I need based on my swatch.
Next, let's get the knitting instructions.
You might want to use
Interactive Knitting, but
that's a topic for another day.
Here's a shortcut you may not have found.
Click this button and you can now
choose your preferred printing method.
If you use garment notation or Japanese
notation, if you use that format,
you'll want to align the columns.
Tick this box, it'll
make it easier to read.
Now you might be tempted to work your
shaping over every other row, but notice
that DesignaKnit is accurately creating
the shaping to make your desired length.
I hope this tutorial is helpful.
The tools you used for this
exercise will help you create
any other shape and DesignaKnit.